it's one thing you know what you've said
and that sort of thing but then when you
watch it back and you see what your face
is doing when you say that to someone
you watch their reaction random looking
at you or just how it really permeates
another person for you what was it like
watching that watching yourself and
watching her I've uh I've always thought
that that for me as an artist music is
evidence of life yes in a way
and I think having this film now really
takes that to the next level where it's
it is evidence of of love I think in a
way but it's also evidence of like what
you said like being a moat so being able
to step outside and watch that back it's
it's it's very humbling but it's also
very healing because it's it's just
again it's just evidence of like okay
this is what we're working we're on a
journey together and this is just part
of the work I hope that people
understand that your reactions and
interactions within collaboration and
we're all collaborating as couples all
day whether it's pass me the salt for
you know boiling the water or it kids to
school or whatever it is or did you send
the check for that bill these are all
challenging things after a long time
together and we can trigger each other
and so when the face doesn't look kind
during an interaction or when there's a
tone in the voice it's for four women
for me for people a lot of us it can be
like violence it can be it can trigger
something in a nervous system and so I
think it what's so exciting is that here
you have this musical project that could
open up some of this dialogue some of
some of these ideas for for people to to
get into and to speak there need a name
what what irks them but name also name
also what what motivates them yeah you
know what makes them feel good like you
know rain says in one of our songs I
can't remember the exact lyric right now
but it's like tell me when it's good not
just when it's bad so if I'm criticizing
him all day that also just repeats a
cycle but if also it's true how you do
that early in a relationship you talk
about all the great things the other
people do and then afterwards you're
just pulling them apart picking them
apart beating them up so it's nice for
me to to have him
let me know through a coach a marriage
coach that like I can't live like that
you have to pick spots you know and me
to respect that okay I mean I'm gonna
swallow that one and then you know this
is one that I have to talk to him about
and the neat thing about the music is
that we're able to get to the heart of
matters you know metaphorically within
the actual writing of music reign rights
you know I can change Wow
how do I never get mad get mad at a
human being who may not ever freaking
change it's always learning that he's
gonna try I think at the end of the day
you have to look at it it's like we're
committed to the journey I think I say
that in the beginning of thumb it's like
I'm here for a reason in one of our
therapy sessions it's like coaching
session why do you keep saying it's a
coaching session and not a merits or a
counseling what I think therapy is weird
I do I'm from Winnipeg and I am seeing a
therapist right at the heart of the
matter I'm a really meat and potatoes
kind of gal like even the fact that I'm
a yogi is like weird to me like I do
yoga every day is weird okay but but you
know the truth is that we are great all
of us at what we do so you might be an
awesome plumber you might be an amazing
teacher but how are you as a wife how
are you as a mom I'm not I'm not a
perfect mom I'm probably a better wife
than I am mom like there are things that
I need help I need to read I need a
coach you're calling this a coat it's
not good I'm somehow so damaged that I
can't figure it out it's that my
modeling may not be suit have been
suitable for this era and time period
and for Who I am as different than where
I grew up in my parents so you see this
is getting to you as a toolkit and and
putting those tools into practice and
being comfortable with that I'm not good
at everything but I'm in this role and I
want to be a great wife and mom one of
the things in the the in the documentary
or the movie I think that's gonna speak
to a lot of women is that feeling of
whether it's your partner or a boss or
nothing is feeling dismissed dismissed
and lonely not heard that's right and
have you figured out a way through this
documentary
still working on that oh my gosh I can
with ease tell my my partner okay you
know my my feeling of being dismissed is
happening right now can we work can we
figure that out can you know that right
now he may he may be in a position to
heal me in that moment with his loving
powers of being my partner or he me not
and I can't come to my like it's it's a
process right I'm especially if you look
at we've been together for over 20 years
now so there's there's all this baggage
it's you have to work backwards and you
have to you know I almost have to go
back to the beginning but again it's
it's once you're committed then you
start seeing those little kind of
triumphs and in the film is like like I
said at the beginning it's like it's a
great it's a great thing to have for us
as as evidence of like okay we're not
perfect at it but we're working at it
and we're both committed and we're
willing to keep working and again the
music is is something that really
parallels this whole journey as it is
it's incredibly important to that
because it isn't yeah musics like the
hero in the film for me every couple is
not making music the way rain and I are
together but they are making music they
are collaborating in their way and and
so I don't it doesn't really matter what
way that is we have to master that art
and realize that the only person on the
planet that like I need happy or to
please is my husband a friend of ours
how some of the most profound things and
I know a lot not a lot of people have
seen the film yet buddy Adam from Warner
said it's it's so amazing what he took
away from the film in the sense of like
everyone just needs to find their music
in the sense of we're all if you're in a
relationship you're all you're it's a
constant work you're always trying to
evolve you're always trying to do better
and at the same time you you do have
something outside of just doing the work
that you need to find that you're
connected with yeah yeah yeah and what
if you can't then that's when it's
really over yeah
you know it's not yeah and we're lucky
we have music as a connector right now I
think also what Adam was saying though
was like he's not married right so for
him no no no no I'm just I'm just no
you're like vibrating I think what is
your question about that he was just
saying that music has so much value yes
and in this in this fast-paced world
right in this fast-paced world we live
in
yes music is healing music is a medicine
from the gods Anna maybe there was -
maybe there's two ways he was saying it
really I think the one thing that we
said - documentary - which was really
great was when was the last time you
spent time just together and I've been
married for just ten years this year and
I can't remember the last time and I
said it affect you well the documentary
affected me a lot Kevin I had a good
chat that quit because we haven't that's
it we haven't and so now we're planning
one because of that because of us like
we haven't watered the grass in a little
while and we need to figure that out
because we're so focused on career and
the family and all of that maybe you
know people analyzing our body language
together so I'm just it was in the other
room during your life this is good over
me so here's the next question
it's dangerous for men it is dangerous
out there cuz I got fired up I'm not
gonna lie right
I was texting you the science says that
it's 70% women yes men that have a lot
of this sort of you know surreal feeling
like that you know and and so that's
okay because it's gonna be 30% men that
are like hey you needed that are gonna
feel that way as well can I ask this
question you can't wait to get fired up
music it is actually about the music
you're gonna love it
then you're gonna say Cheryl this is the
best the masses when she mentioned the
word a phrase about the bastion right
there yeah I you're like inside outside
the whole thing what was it about that
phrase or the way it was put what
happened and you'll see it in the
documentary no seriously I just because
I was an artist I am think I know why
but
it felt bigger it really comes down to
we this is like the one time besides the
first Our Lady peace record that I made
right this is the one time that we've
been able and it's in it and it's like
metaphorically but also like
legitimately we were isolated right we
are away from everything okay so we're
in this hotel room on this beautiful
island called st. Pierre and we have
nothing around us like it's just the two
of us so as soon as Chantal said you
know how what are we writing the song
for and to bring any in the wolf's any
outside for us for me is like it was
evil because it this was like the this
was gonna be the most pure music or we
wanted it to be that was the expectation
pure musical experience like back to the
den naivety of being in are of an artist
back to the fact that there is there's
no business surrounding any of this it's
really just for us so we start bringing
other other other touch points and it's
just like oh my god why we like why
would we ever do that and it it was it
was a moment you know and then even when
she corrected it and was like but I
didn't but I wasn't but you said it you
know sometimes people don't mean it I
said stupid and I didn't mean it
different this is not good I need okay
no that was so that's what I wanted to
know but the music is beautiful I think
I think though you know what she's
saying maybe maybe saying it's it's
there's also the Peace of maybe maybe
what she's kind of saying is do you see
where my reaction or my hurt is coming
from like she wants to know if you're
also aware that that was harsh I mean I
yeah but you know also you fix things
when he says stuff do i yeah really yeah
i sews them you he will say something
and you realize that i don't like what
he said so you're making it better so it
protects him I'm DC that I saw you do
ater I saw you do it during the live too
it's very interesting you know what
asked my mom like don't mess with my man
I and I'm not no no no this whole talk
is so interesting you are saying that I
am like you know I mean rainin I've been
together since I was 22 years old he's
my old he's my new he's my everything
yeah and and he's the father of my kids
he is the most like incredible father
and husband and dedicated soul mate
partner and so I get him that's it you
know and and no one else like I said no
one else needs to like him or love him
no one else needs to like her love me
just just him and I yeah that's it and
that's the science of partnership too
that's not just me talking and being
naive or being some kind of like you
know weirdo that's that's the reality of
it only he and I need to agree you need
to get it
uh-huh and so I understand and he'll
apologize later so that's the pump how
are the kids with it have is it rained
I'm so sorry no one wants to I just want
to be friends like Poulet will have a
doll bring it a safe the music is great